in one of the most famous scenes from a
man for all seasons and perhaps the best
thomas moore is arguing with his
son-in-law william roper about the
meaning and value of the law and roper
wants more to arrest a guy that that he
roper has judged as bad though he can't
explain what law the guy has actually
broken
more calmly explains that being bad
generally speaking isn't against the law
in and of itself you can't go arresting
people for that reason because that
would be that that would be against the
law to do roper indignant accuses more
of giving the devil the benefit of law
and moore says that he would indeed give
even the devil the benefit of law
roper looking to take the moral high
ground says that well he would cut down
every law in england to get to you know
get a chance to go after the devil if
that's what it takes to which moore
responds and says
when the last law was down the devil
turned round on you where would you hide
the laws all being flat this country is
planted thick with laws from coast to
coast and if you cut them down do you
really think you could stand upright in
the winds that blow then yes i'd give
the devil the benefit of law for my own
safety's sake
now i've thought about that scene a lot
as i watched the kyle rittenhouse case
it's clear now and has always been clear
to any honest observer that ridden house
committed no crime he's an innocent man
innocent boy really as he was only 17 at
the time of this incident
but the left to include the corporate
media big tech democrat party the d.a in
the case
they're willing to destroy the law rip
it to shreds cut down every law in the
united states if they have to to punish
kyle rittenhouse
now at least roper in a man for all
seasons wanted to cut down the law to
get to the devil which would have been a
bad enough idea as thomas moore
explained kyle rittenhouse though
is not the devil he is in fact a good
man even a hero as we'll talk about
today
the men he killed in self-defense were
far more devilish than he is
if anything then the left is cutting
down the law to defend the devil but the
effect will be the same in the end if
they succeed
we'll be a nation with no law a nation
with nothing that can call itself a
justice system
now there's plenty more to say about the
tribal let's begin by playing a few
important clips from yesterday
rittenhouse took the stand in his own
defense
no doubt a risky move to have him
testify considering that the state had
totally failed to prove its case or even
provide enough evidence to justify
bringing the case in the first place
the defense as we know basic uh basic
law here the debt defense is not there
to prove anything it's up to the
prosecution to provide proof of the
crime if the prosecution can't and
certainly couldn't in this case
then that should be the end of it
there's really no need for the defense
to call a single witness much less put
the accused himself on the stand
that's the way it should work but that
depends on the jury understanding what
its role is supposed to be and acting on
that understanding without any ulterior
motives unfortunately you can't always
rely on that which is probably why the
defense tried to seal the deal by
putting kyle up there
having watched his entire testimony
though i can't get inside the minds of
the jurors it seems to me that the
gamble paid off
because kyle
didn't come across like a cold-blooded
murderer as he has been cast
he seemed very much as he is a kid
a kid who suffered a terrible trauma and
had to fight for his life
in the moment on the streets of kenosha
and is now having to fight for his life
once again
it's the kind of pressure that would
take an
unimaginable psychological toll on
anybody especially somebody so young
and that toll that burden was made
apparent early in kyle's testimony when
he broke down on the stand let's watch
that
once i take that step back i look over
my shoulder and
mr rosenbaum
mr rosenbaum was now running
from
my right side
um
and
i was cornered from in front of me with
mr zaminski
and they were
they were
people right there
now that's what a panic attack looks
like for anyone who's not familiar
of course as expected left us on social
media if you're expecting them to have
any
humanity then you were sorely mistaken
they mocked him for this display
accusing him of crying crocodile tears
there are many posts like this one from
anna navarro
she said kyle rittenhouse shot and
killed anthony hubert 26 joseph
rosenbaum 36 and injured gage gross
krause now 27. think about how much
their loved ones have cried real anguish
and grief not crocodile
now
tears
funny to hear people like this deride a
kid for crying on the stand as he faces
false murder charges
kyle rittenhouse was violently attacked
by a mob had to defend himself with
lethal force and immediately upon doing
that he was in order to save his life
immediately upon doing that all of the
most powerful forces in society
conspired and have been conspiring to
conspiring to ruin him and take away his
freedom
in the face of this he cried
meanwhile people like anna if a stand-up
comedian tells a joke
or if a politician they don't like is
elected
or if you misgender them they'll break
down in tears so they cry all the time
about everything
wielding their fragile emotions like a
battering ram
yet they think they're in a position to
look with contempt on a kid who cries
while facing the kind of pressure that
the vast majority of humans on planet
earth have never faced
and will never face
we talked to you yesterday about how the
word trauma is is way overused and
everyone's running around all the time
claiming how they're traumatized by
everything
well here is inappropriate
use this is an application for trauma
this is a kid who has suffered real
trauma
that night that is a traumatic
experience and what he's gone through
over the last year in this trial also
traumatic experience
one other point about this navarro
attempts to solicit sympathy for
rosenbaum and huber the two men who were
killed
the media has been playing this game for
a year trying to tug on our heartstrings
calling on us on us to mourn poor
rosenbaum and huber
so it becomes relevant then to point
because they have introduced this right
just just like in a trial and and now
we're in the court of public opinion
they have opened this door
here by by talking about how we should
feel so bad for rosenbaum and hubert
and on that note it becomes relevant to
point out
that rosenbaum was not only a sex
offender but in fact a serial child
rapist
he molested and annually raped multiple
boys
he had just recently got out of prison
for sex crimes when this happened
okay so
he is a serial child rapist goes to
prison gets out of prison and then uh
and then one of the first things he does
is he tries to chase someone down and
kill
them to put it as generous as i can
joseph rosenbaum was a piece of human
filth
i mean that's how i feel about child
rapists i don't know about you
huber was slightly better but only by
comparison uh rather than a child rapist
he was merely a repeat repeat domestic
abuser guilty of among other things
choking and strangling a woman
now these facts may not be relevant to
the shootings themselves but they are
relevant if we're being asked to feel
sympathy for the quote unquote victims
or feel any emotion towards them other
than contempt
riddenhaus was justified in his actions
that night because huber and rosenbaum
were violently attacking him leaving him
no choice as has been incontrovertibly
proven but it's also worth noting that
the world is a better place
without people especially like joseph
rosenbaum in it
bad person
and it strikes me that the left mourns a
pedophile child rapist only a few days
after celebrating when a different child
molester's name was put on a navy ship
um harvey milk maybe eventually joseph
rosenbaum will get his own ship too
so these people really seem to be big
fans of child rapists you might start
drawing some conclusions about them
now back to the trial perhaps all we
really need to say in analyzing the
state's cross-examination is that they
actually spent time
questioning kyle
about the video games that he plays
which put him in the position of having
to explain to the da
that video games and real life are not
the same
isn't one of the things people do in
these video games try and kill everyone
else with your guns
yeah the video game it's just a video
game it's not real life
sir isn't it true that you've played
super mario world
is it not true that in that game you
jump on little mushroom men and kill
them
sir
establishing a pattern
so this is what grasping at straws looks
like and that was if anything that was
like the highlight that was the best
moment from the d.a
uh the maybe the whole trial that's like
as good as it got
it was an absurd and misleading line of
questioning but at least it wasn't a
grave constitutional violation the
constitutional violations happened at a
different point when the d.a began
questioning kyle about the fact that
kyle exercised his right to remain
silent after his arrest
prosecutors
are not allowed to stand in front of a
jury and imply that silence is
incriminating because the whole point of
your right to remain silent
is that you are not being forced to
incriminate yourself
okay the judge then had to jump in and
remind the d.a of this fact
you need to account for this
your honor i don't want to
i want a jury here
he's commenting on my client's right to
remain silent
you know your honor i am making the
point that
after hearing everything in the case now
he's
tailoring his story to what has already
been introduced
the problem is this is a grave
constitutional violation
for you to talk about
the defendants silence
and that is and and in your right
you're right on the you're right on the
borderline
and you may
you may be over but it better stop
understand
this is
i can't think of the case the initial
case on it but it's this is not
permitted
now it's not often that you hear a judge
accuse a d.a of a grave constitutional
violation in open court
that's how things have gone to this
trial
a little bit later on as the prosecutor
continued with lines of questioning that
were not admissible and which had been
he'd been warned to avoid by the judge
continued along this path the judge was
then forced to intervene again
and this time he wasn't quite as kind
about it
why would you think that that made it
okay for you without any advance notice
to bring this matter before the jury
you are already you were i was
astonished
when you began your examination by
commenting on the defendant's post
arrest silence that's basic law it's
been basic law in this country for 40
years 50 years i have no idea why you
would do something like that and it
gives
well i'll i'll leave it at that
so i don't know what you're up to
now i think what he was going to say
there not to try to read his mind but um
maybe words to the effect of like if
there's a conviction here this is this
is an appeal all day long i mean
if there is somehow a conviction here
a grave miscarriage of justice
the good news at least a whole lot of
bad news the good news at least is that
this is appealed all day long i mean
you've got you have to judge in the case
telling the prosecutor that he committed
a grave constitutional violation
is that he said you you crossed the line
and did that
look there there are gray areas in life
there are times when the line between
good and bad you know the good guy and
the bad guy might not be as clear
this is not one of those times okay the
bad guys
may as well be wearing name tags that
say hi i'm the bad guy that's how brazen
all of this is
and that leads me to two final points
one is
you know what what are they what are
they really doing here why are they
going after this kid
well much of the prosecutor's
questioning revolved around the gun he
was using and how big it was and how
scary it was
you know he he he observes the
prosecutor does uh that kyle rittenhouse
had had a bigger gun than than what uh
his assailant had
so you had a you had a bigger gun i mean
he had a smaller gun so why were you
with the bigger gun worried about a
smaller gun well i don't know maybe
because a smaller gun when you fire it
would still kill me
it became clear as this was going on
that the second amendment is what he is
trying to prosecute
our second amendment right our right to
defend ourselves is on trial
much of his line of questioning was
about really about that
uh where kyle rittenhouse became he
wasn't even testifying about himself he
became a
they were he was being treated like a
constitutional scholar a firearms expert
kyle rittenhouse is a symbol
this is not about him personally
certainly isn't about the of the events
of that night or the facts of the case
he's a stand-in and he represents not
only the constitutional rights of the
left to test but also the kind of people
that the left detests
just like derek chauvin before him
written house is a blood sacrifice meant
to atone for the sins of all white men
his personal guilt or innocence is not
relevant
just as a goat sacrificed on a burning
altar is not selected due to its
personal foibles it is burned as a
symbol and that's the role that kyle is
playing here
second
all that should matter
in a case
is that kyle is not guilty of committing
murder
you know that should be the end of it
that's all that that's all that matters
legally even if he was reckless or
stupid or he shouldn't have been there
quote unquote
uh even if he is a terrible person
even if he's the devil
none of that matters or should matter
legally
and yet i still think it's important to
point out
that kyle rittenhouse
is is uh not a bad person and i don't
think he's even stupid or reckless and
he's not he's more than merely innocent
he's more than that i think he's a hero
in my estimation
yes he put he put himself in harm's way
by showing up to the riot
but where i come from
putting yourself in harm's way in order
to defend innocent people and protect
property is heroic
that's what heroes do that's like the
definition of a hero
and yes to protect property too it tells
you a lot about you know
a lot of people on the left that they
and we got this from the prosecutor a
lot too well you would use violent force
to protect property
it's just property
well again he used the violence force to
protect human life his own life
that's why he had the gun was to protect
himself
but um but you know what you know
something yeah i mean using force to
protect property that is also morally
justified it's not only morally
justified it's heroic
what does the mob have some kind of
right well the mob all they want to do
is burn down buildings
they have no right to do that
this is people's property this is their
livelihood their lives their businesses
that are being destroyed
yes you could
i would use lethal force to protect if
someone was trying to burn down my home
i would shoot them i would even if there
was nobody else inside
why because it's my home it's my
property
and you have no right to do what you're
doing right now
and i can use force to stop you and i
would
but even when faced with a mortal threat
from a violent mob still rittenhouse
waited until the very last moment to
fire
he tried to preserve the lives of the
people who wanted him dead
until they left him no recourse
i would call that courage not stupidity
though to cowards perhaps
it's hard to tell the difference between
the two
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt well show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content